so i'm sorry the reason why i asked you
that question is because
i finally walked away in march of 2018
and then it was probably another five or
six
months before i became a trump fan and
the reason why i became a trump fan
is because i i mean i developed a
hatred for the media the media that i
once loved i loved rachel maddow i loved
anderson cooper i loved that
stupid idiot don lemon i loved all of
this wow that one's tough
horrible people well he's just the worst
he is the thing about don lemon is like
rachel maddow i think
and even anderson cooper they're savvy
enough to know what they're doing
like it's intentional manipulation i
don't believe that don lemon
actually knows it's a lie i mean when he
goes on the tv crying every day and
freaking out and
like he literally thinks that the
country is overrun by white supremacists
like
like he's not in on the meetings when
they're like like let's run this
narrative tonight
he just is reading from the teleprompter
he's like white supremacists
um but um i don't know if i
remember oh so when i finally discovered
so when i finally discovered how much i
hate the the media
and how toxic they are and what they're
doing in the ways especially that
they're manipulating minorities and
stuff
then i started to see that this
rhetoric from trump and his
take no bs and does not just take no bs
i mean he's
he's a troll he's a funny funny
troll and it's like it's so empowering
to all of these people on the right
conservatives who a lot of these people
they're just living day to day paycheck
to paycheck trying to figure out if
they're gonna have enough money to pay
their bills next time can i send my kids
to college
meanwhile they're getting called nazis
racist white supremacists they're
getting called privileged
they're i mean they're getting crapped
on every day in the worst
possible way demeaned just dragged
through the mud and they have no voice
and they have no power
and here you've got the most powerful
man in the office trolling his
ass off on their behalf and it's
beautiful it is the most gorgeous
beautiful thing
about being alive right now i i love
this man
i think i think the the like it is uh to
clarify
i think it's hilarious when when trump
won i had my feet up i was
laughing just i could not stop it was
really
hard oh yeah absolutely who did you vote
for i didn't vote for anybody
why because i obama man fool me once
shame on you for me twice
so i was like i'm not playing this game
anymore i'm so over this i was chilling
in dc with cassandra fairbanks
she was on board for trump surrounded in
this newsroom by a bunch of democrats
they were gloating and they were the
perfect example of
snooty elitist like trump is gonna lose
oh he's so pathetic when they start when
they announced he was gonna sue because
once you know nevada was coming in or
something
they're like here it comes now started
laughing and then we were watching the
new york times had this meter
that was pointed all the way to hillary
clinton 99 chance of winning
it slowly started moving up towards
trump and cassandra
you know you know you know cassandra
right yeah yeah so cassandra's watching
this
and she's like oh my oh my god like it's
it's going up for trump and then i
remember when it crossed to 50 50
and we were both looking at each other i
wasn't in the bag for anybody i just was
i i was so fed up with the democrats
because i felt like obama
spam spent my face over over war stuff
and so i was like
i don't like hillary i was really mad
about bernie because i was
i was big for bernie at the time i was
like bernie is this consistent guy
oh that's very different today but
anyway so so i was like hillary's about
to get her comeuppance
i will laugh if donald trump wins the
meter starts going further and further
and then when it got to the point where
it was like trump is going to win and
nothing's stopping it i just started
laughing everyone in the room is like
crying
cassandra was crying tears of joy
everyone else is crying tears of like
shock and sorrow and i was just laughing
taking off their i'm with her sticker
you know what it was for me it was oh
man it was cathartic it was like you
get this week you played dirty games and
now you
lose so good so did you think he
could win before he won you know what's
interesting is
part of me always felt like he would win
but i felt like the machine wouldn't let
him win interesting i feel that way
right now too
right like everything i see all the time
the democrat like biden
he's not even i don't know if you saw my
tweet about it but it's see i said
you know biden harris is kind of like
when you're in a rush and your socks are
dirty so you grab two random ones out of
the drawer right
and you're not worried about impressing
anybody the dairy queen anyway so you
don't care and you're walking
it just it's it feels like they don't
care like they're just like
yeah but part of me still feels like
with all the mail and voting stuff
everything they're doing that they're
going to play dirty games to try and
shut them out
i think so for sure can i tell you a
funny little anecdote about the media
okay so you were talking about all the
people in the press room who are being
so arrogant
i have a good friend who works for
a very popular national morning tv show
on abc that rhymes we can see
morning america and
see what you wrote down and um
very very liberal uh big trump hater she
is
and after i'd had my conversion uh she
and i were having dinner it was very
tense
she's actually really cut me out of her
life uh
she's one of like 90 of my former
friends who cut me out
but she did we did have a dinner
together after that and um
and i was trying delicately to explain
to her how biased the media is
now i didn't think that she would take
this personally because she's kind of on
i mean she's more than like the
production in
but she said to me um she's like well i
you know i'm
i am the media and she was like i just i
don't agree with what you're saying and
i take that very personally and i'm like
well i'm sorry i don't know what to tell
you but i was like
i i think that there's really clearly
bias in the way that the media covers
and
handles trump and she was like i know
and she goes and she goes
well she goes i guess on election night
we did not even bother
to create the trump graphic if he won
whoa yeah wow
they created the hillary graphic but
they didn't even bother to create the
trump wins graphic so we've often talked
about how like how did the media miss
this
there was a study that was done uh i've
said it several times
from uh i think it's university of
illinois at champaign-urbana
that found the beltway bubble is worse
now
than it was in 2016. okay so they're
doing the same thing
you get meet the press going on and
saying like oh joe biden he's going to
win trump's only only got a 17
chance of winning and i think i think
her name's savannah guthrie i'm not sure
she's like
we've heard this story before why should
we believe it and they're like oh
don't be silly joe biden's gonna win the
beltway reporters
they follow each other and no one else
so all they're doing is playing a game
of telephone with each other all day
every day
right and so they just keep recycling
the same garbage information without
actually googling anything
but they shouldn't even be running pulls
after what happened in 2016.
they should be so pole shy at this point
i can't believe they're still going with
it well the poll thing is interesting
it's because
they don't know how to actually pull
trump's base
yes and so they've admitted it straight
up admitted it and right now there was
it was an article from politico that
said
we still don't know how to accurately
pull donald trump's base
and i'm like then why are you polling if
you put up the polls
our margin of error is ten percent
because we can't you know we don't know
how to call
contact these people yeah yeah trump's
base was new voters
i so i think what what really helped me
and prevented me from you know um
actually let me put it this way you know
bernie sanders and trump had a lot in
common
yeah uh early on and so for me right
away
i'm on the ground i was covering these
trump rallies i was meeting
these people who are going to the
rallies and i was hearing a lot of them
say
you know bernie has said these things
too so we like him but
he's kind of too far left for us and we
want a businessman
and then after bernie sanders lost the
nomination
i actually met several trump supporters
who flipped from bernie to trump who
said straight up their biggest issue was
nafta and the tpp
that that you know i met one older guy
who said look i work at a factory i have
kids
the factory is going to shut down next
year bernie sanders said that he was
going to
you know ntp and and deal with nafta and
that would have saved my factory so
i i had one guy met him i think this was
in janesville wisconsin
who told me that because bernie sanders
was a politician who had the experience
he thought he was the right choice even
though he was really far left
and then once bernie got the boot donald
trump was his only choice
right there's a lot of people i met like
that yeah i've met those people too and
i think that a lot of people are
surprised
when they hear people for a lot of
people there's a
a closer gap between
trump and bernie than there is between
biden and bernie
yeah that is a farther leap for a lot of
people yeah hillary biden
i went to a bunch of these rallies and i
remember one from fort lauderdale
i was i was talking to this woman she
was very nice and she told me that
she had never she had not voted before
and she was like middle-aged
and she's like i've never voted for
anybody in my life i never cared and
then donald trump came around and
started talking about issues that matter
to me and my family
right and now we're all here having a
good time we're barbecuing they were
having hot dogs
having a good time hanging out trump is
hilarious i think a lot of people left
they really don't want to admit it but
the man is a funny guy oh he's hilarious
and
i'm sorry i was going to say i just i
the one thing i loved was when he made
fun of himself for being orange
like the lights in this room they're
making me look orange it was it's
hilarious yes
so you know for me i didn't i don't want
to vote for anybody because i felt like
you know i'm going to vote for somebody
and then in the first couple of years
trump he brought on bolton you know he
brought on some people he should not
have brought on
he was getting involved in drone strikes
missile strikes
but he's cleaned up his act absolutely
now he's now i think he's
wow no new wars and actually trying to
end the you know the the war in
afghanistan in iraq and
the establishment is trying to shut him
down that makes me really angry
can i ask how you feel about his
handling of coronavirus
i think it's fine i think uh yeah
absolutely i do too
it's strange to me how many times we
hear people say he should have done a
better job
what he runs the federal government he
banned travel from certain areas he
addressed the nation
and now it's up to the governors to
decide what is the appropriate level of
action right
joe biden announces we're going to do a
mandatory national mass mandate and you
don't have the authority to do that
right well and it's also i mean it look
i know a lot of people say oh we
shouldn't be politicizing this it's
already politicized it's already
political
and let's not pretend like it's not
you know governors on the left who want
to keep everything shut down who are
pushing more
i mean people on the right are like
let's go let's get let's get back to
work let's figure this out
but then the people you know it's the
the democrats who are also saying
trump ruined the economy trump ruined
the economy well no coronavirus ruined
the economy right
and you want to keep the economy ruined
by keeping everything shut down and then
you want to blame trump
because you want to keep everything shut
down exactly yeah
we're in new jersey we're we're uh in
the philly burbs
yes the adolescent gym uh-huh it's about
five miles away
okay yes they got it they arrested those
two guys yes
we're look we're looking i i looked at
all the data i'm looking at what the
scientists are saying
and many are speculating now we've
reached herd immunity a long time ago
yet why are they still locking down
deaths are way way down
hospitalizations are ridiculously down
yes asymptomatic cases
have popped up a little bit starting to
go back down again yes
yet they're still saying it went from 15
days to slow the spread
to 155 and we're not doing anything
until we have a vaccine
right when were we ever trying to
prevent everyone from getting sick
that's i've been asking that question a
lot and why are we also
now that look the the number one thing
that we should be looking at is deaths
that's
really honestly all that we should be
caring about i don't care if there's
seven
billion cases if the majority of them
are going to recover and everybody's
going to be fine but the death count is
not really rising at any significant
level
by any metric and so why now are people
becoming so deranged about mask wearing
and these you know
i mean from our culture and our society
people are becoming
uh absolutely nuts and i'll tell you
something too i travel
a lot in my work a lot a lot and i've
said
new jersey is the most coveted deranged
state totally entire
country people are out of control here i
had like
three incidents and one wawa uh one guy
four feet tall
came up to me and threatened to beat the
hell out of me for not wearing a mask
for not wearing a mask wow
yeah and it was like this huge incident
and everyone in the wawa wanted to get
involved in it and i was just like
and he's like scream this close to my
face pulling his mask down so i can hear
him as he's threatening to beat me up
and i'm not wearing a mask yeah there's
there's a there's a park not too far
from here we went to nobody was wearing
masks
well that's good yeah good i'm glad i
wish there was more of that in new
jersey
the thing to me is like people wearing
masks in their cars and outside
that to me look i wear them those are my
favorite people i'm the car by
themselves
i have no problem wearing a mask in
stores i think it's not even an
issue to me i don't care sure go to the
home depot or whatever and i just pop it
on in my my own business i leave it take
it off
but it is the people who are outside who
are acting like
we're living through the apocalypse
right and that that's a level of
derangement that
is very scary to me yes i think
my theory is to why this is happening
the media doesn't allow conversations
that challenge
orthodoxy yes within reason like they
will ban conservatives they will ban
people who have moderate opinion they'll
even ban liberals who challenge the
status quo
it's all about maintaining that that
fear and that paranoia
because it's like an uncontrollable mob
that demands it
if you come out and you say something
like we've got harvey rich of yale
mdphd saying hydroxychloroquine can help
not a cure but it can actually get us
through this and they they panic and
they freak out and they ban the videos
they shut it down
even though newsweek published him and
then it's a huge panic
fiasco of how dare you publish this
article if the only acceptable opinion
is that the world is ending
then the only thing anyone's ever going
to hear is that's worse it's worse every
day it's worse even though it's not
worse
it's getting better right but even with
all the charts
it's still the apocalypse nope we're not
opening up until we have a vaccine
we flatten the curve the curve cannot be
any flat flatter like we
actually new york i think new york city
had no deaths yesterday
actually so i need to fact check that
fact check me on that one but if that's
the case then there's no fighting
anything there's no curve anymore it's
literally nothing there
right well and you know uh people talk a
lot about how
you know in our society today you know
young people are not taught
how to think but just what to think they
don't really know how to think clearly
for themselves in a way i think that
kind of carries over
into society at large because you know
the whole
and look i'm no great scientist don't
get me wrong but i know
that the whole point of scientific
theory and you know hypothesis
hypothesis and experimentation is you
rule out what does not work you don't
start by saying
this is the right answer and no one's
allowed to challenge me
so i mean i i we why we're telling
certain doctors who are
contradicting the the narrative why
we're shutting them down banning them on
social media and canceling them
rather than testing their theory and
saying your theory is bunk this doesn't
work
it's crazier than that breitbart got
their video removed and they were just
reporting on a press conference
by all means i think some of the things
i said were absolutely incorrect
yes like i i do not believe it's fair to
say that
hydroxychloroquine is a cure that's not
that's i i look to harvey rich md phd
because
some of the doctors actually cited him
and he says it's just something that
would help if used very early on
that's what he said so far don't take my
word for it and i always have to preface
this
just talk to your doctor my opinion
should you should not be coming from
from
to me right you know do it on the
internet for an opinion no you should
you should actually talk to your doctor
about it i'll give you the better advice
the bigger issue is that news outlets
are actually getting shut down the
conversation gets silenced
right and then regular people are
sitting there watching cnn with only one
allowed opinion yes
it's worse today than it's ever been yes
you hate life
life is miserable and everyone's dying
yes and then regular people out in the
you know middle of the country throwing
the football around they're going to
barbecues
right everything's normal now when
you're talking about uh masks and kind
of how you feel about it how do you feel
about these
jerks who don't wear them on airplanes
people like yeah
you who i'm i'm going to be completely
honest with you
i absolutely sir saw this happen i
rolled my eyes and i'm like why didn't
you just wear a mask dude
okay can we get into it absolutely yeah
i i rolled my eyes
yeah and i was like just where it comes
stupid brandon strong stupid
stupid walk away idiot always looking
for attention
yeah um no that story was very much
misreported
and there's kind of like a a dual side
to it too which was it was one of
uh in all of my trials and tribulations
since i started walk away and there's
been a lot
um that was the most helpless honestly
i've ever felt
because almost no one from the
conservative media came to my aid
when i mean it just it was spinning out
of control and fast and it went
international
i was i was on the airplane because they
took me off the flight
and they actually put me on another
flight and by the time i landed
uh would it was on cnn oh wow
yeah people were sending me screenshots
that had my name my picture and
it was yeah and i was like uh so what
actually happened
and you and maybe you'll disagree with
this too sure but
i just want you to know what actually
happened i was on the airplane
and like i said it's not unusual for me
to travel every week sometimes multiple
times a week
and up until that point i had never worn
a mask on an airplane
ever and no one had ever said a word
about it it had never been a problem and
also i wasn't the only one there were
i'm not maybe even the majority were
but there were i was not the only person
not wearing a mask on the plane
and i fly a lot so i know that on every
flight
up until that point they would make an
announcement at the beginning please be
courteous and respectful to those who
are unable to wear a mask
so clearly it's their policy that not
everybody has to wear a mask
right that some people cannot and you
should be
courteous and respectful to those who
cannot so
i had never worn a mask i'd never been
asked to wear a mask before on a flight
and i
i was doing nothing out of the ordinary
on that day i was on the plane
we were very close to taking off and
this
overzealous flight attendant walked up
to me and said
literally this is how the conversation
began first first
uh comments after about she said sir you
need to put on your mask right now or
you can't be on this plane
that that's what she said to me and i
said that's not true
and she was like it is true it is true
she was like you need to put on a mask
right now i'm removing you from this
flight and i was like
you can't do that she said yes it's the
law i said it's not the law
and she was and she was arguing with me
about it being a lot and i kept saying
that's not a federal law it's not a law
that you have to wear a mask
now this is where i involved myself and
how stupid it got
because i got so my ego got so involved
in the argument about whether or not it
was a law
that i probably should have just dropped
it that would have been the right thing
to do because i really
i was just annoyed by her tone i was
annoyed by her aggressiveness
and she was wrong it's not a law well
hold on
flight attendants can tell you what to
do absolutely within reason but if they
if
a flight attendant walks up to the
captain and says remove that man you're
out absolutely yeah
absolutely but that's we haven't gotten
that far yet right right she was just
telling me you have to wear the
the mask because it's the law right and
uh
so i was arguing with her about that so
she went she got another flight
attendant who came back and this flight
attendant decided to start in with the
same thing
she was like sir the law is that you
have to wear the mask and i was like i
just said it's not a law
it's not a law you know i mean and again
i'm not saying i'm right here
i was being stupid and i was having it
you know a petty thing where i wanted to
point out that there's a difference
between law and policy
and i didn't like their tone whatever so
once i got to the point where i realized
i was like this is really dumb i just
said look
i just want to point out i was like none
of you have even bothered to ask if i
might have a medical condition that
prevents me from being able to wear a
mask
and they still didn't ask i mean they
were still just kind of like
so into the i think we're gonna win
we're gonna win
that's exactly what it was so they left
the two of them left
when they came back they brought the
pilots and they brought a manager
from american airlines and the manager
from american airlines was
like really not feeling me like from the
moment she walked over like just
and see this is another thing that
bothers me too in this age of like mask
wearing in covet
anybody in the hospitality industry has
given themselves a complete pass
to just be a total a-hole whenever they
want i mean you walk into a restaurant
you walk into a hotel
where's your mask put your mask on i'm
like can you still not just be like
good evening sir how are you welcome our
policy here is that you have to wear
like right you know none of that anymore
now people are just giving themselves
carte blanche to be the biggest
jerks that they want to be so the
manager walks up to me
and she had an attitude right from the
beginning and she was just like
uh she was like you know i hear that
you're refusing to wear a mask and
whatever and i'm like
that's not even it i was like your staff
didn't even bother to ask me if i might
there might be a reason why i can't wear
a mask and then
the passengers were getting agitated at
this point just let's go let's go
and that was the moment where the woman
said to me i'm taking you off this
flight and i was like
whoa wow okay and i gave
i put up no resistance i put up no
argument
i gathered my things and i left the
flight and when i got off the flight i
went to the man
a different manager who was waiting
outside and i explained the situation
and that manager said wow it sounds like
you know that was not handled very well
and i was like yeah i agree
and then the the manager that came into
the plane who was
had an attitude she came up to me and
she said
very quietly she was like did anyone
from our staff ask you if you had a
medical condition and i said no that was
my
point all along and she was like okay
well they really should have and i was
like yeah
they really should have so they booked
me on another flight i thought we were
good
wow they said to me um will you wear the
mask on the plane and i was like fine
i'll wear the mask on the plane
i got on the plane wearing the mask i
had a lovely flight with no incident
when i landed cnn was covering the story
how did they find out about it did you
post about it because there was a
reporter on the plane
wow next to me and he's creepy and he
tweeted about it
and then they picked up the story from
his tweet and um
so when i landed at uh my connection
there was an
another manager from american waiting
for me
he wait he was waiting for me at the
gate he apologized
and he said it sounds like this all got
really blown out of proportion and i
said i agree
i thought we were good like i i was i
thought it was over
uh it became a huge story because i
think cnn broke it
and literally within like 24 hours it
went international
and i mean it was really bad and i have
a thick skin i mean it didn't
hurt me or anything but it was you know
they went through my videos
and they found like look how expressive
i am right right so they freeze phrase
moments where i'm like
and they use that as the cover photo and
they're like trump's
angry trump supporter refuses to wear a
mask on plane
and i think the story got so big at that
point that then american airlines called
me about two or three days later and
said you're banned from the airline
wow that's what happened so this was
never
a thing about me feeling that a private
company doesn't have the right
to make their own policies whatever for
me this was just a thing that your
policy
is that some people cannot wear a mask
so don't you feel an obligation to ask a
person if there's a reason why they're
not wearing one
rather than tell them put your mask on
or get off the plane
because that's not your policy not only
that there are tons of stories about how
airlines weren't enforcing mass policies
too
right my thing was very much like look i
i think i saw a video from you
and then i saw the story and i very
passively looked at it and i was just
like just wear the mask whatever man
but but it is interesting because you
could have just said
sorry and put a mask on right but what
if she had like to what to what degree
is
is a request unreasonable or
inappropriate of a flight attendant
so look i'll tell you this i just put
the mask on i got someone sent me this
really cool mask a little beanie on it
yeah i don't i don't really care all
that much so for sure i definitely
rolled my eyes at the story
right but well i'll be honest with you i
i am
absolutely one of those people who sees
the mask as
an exercise in compliance uh that where
it is to wear it especially to be forced
to wear it when you don't want to wear
it is a sign of submission to
a belief system that i don't believe in
to a
theory about this virus that i do not
accept and i don't believe in
at all and so i don't want to be a part
of that and i admit that
however uh i cannot stop traveling if i
stop traveling i have no movement
and so i have to comply with the the
private policies of airlines at this
point to be able to do the work that i
have to do and i hate it
but it's either that or let's not have
walk away before the election which i
think is not a good idea
that i i totally understand like uh i i
have to tell people
hey avoid swearing on the show because
we don't want youtube to get an excuse
to shut us down or anything like that
and there are certain things i can't say
there's notably a
a cia character if you say his name
they'll just
shut the stream will be shut off
instantly yeah that's that's insane to
me
yeah newsworthy and everything but the
way i see it is
do i have a better shot at letting
people know knowing what's going on
by talking about all these things or
should i just get angry and shut it all
down overnight
because i i refuse on something like
saying a name yeah you can't do that
you can't do that now that you know the
story have you changed your mind about
how you feel about it
it's okay if you haven't which about you
about the airline a little bit
no i i feel like i still think you're a
jerk but no i think you were you were
being assertive
i i i totally understand that don't come
to me and tell me
you don't don't make up a fake policy
and come at me right or don't exaggerate
the policy or don't disrespect me
right right like you said if you know
very you're not seeing people
saying i'm sorry sir it's our policy to
wear a mask they're coming at you in a
very aggressive manner right
if someone came to me and got my face
you're less likely you know
it's it's you get more flies with honey
than with vinegar right certainly
let me tell you one quick anecdote of
course i got physically assaulted on an
american airlines flight they refused to
do anything to help me
really yeah i was uh i was boarding a
plane and
usually this is really really funny you
may notice
that uh i just kind of you know wear an
unbuttoned shirt not tucked in with a
beanie on
so i probably don't look like someone
who should be flying first class
i was standing i always do this i am i
have
uh as many people have jokingly referred
to me some kind of obsessive compulsive
whatever
i get up about 20 minutes for every
flight and i get in line i want to get
in i want to get my my carry-on
in and i want to get out of the way as
fast as possible i don't want to be
stuck behind anybody else and i don't
want anyone stuck behind me
so my thing is like if i'm in the first
boarding group i'm in
i'm down and i'm out of your way and
you're out of my way and we're good to
go so i get in line
and this old couple walks past me and
i'm literally like standing they're
about to call
you know the first group they walk right
in front of me to stop in front of me
and so i was confused and i assumed
when when they called you know group one
or whatever for first class they just
stood there and i was like
they must be coach they must have just
you know they're cutting in front
whatever
i walked past the guy and he snapped hey
hey you're yelling
i walk up she scans my ticket they were
first class his wife shoves me
and i i jolt forward and then i turn
around
and i was like uh-uh no way and i told
them that
that lady just like physically attacked
me what they said was
okay we can pull both of you off the
flight
or you can shut up well you shouldn't
have been shoved like that
i thought i shouldn't i shouldn't have
exactly you're asking for it too and so
they they uh brought me you know we went
to the plane
and they were also sitting you know a
couple rows back in first class
and the lady was livid that i was
allowed on or whatever and like i always
sit in the bulkhead i was like seat 1a
and i was i was furious like i
complained for quite a while i was like
i was attacked by this woman who was
angry because she cut me in line and i
didn't do anything
and then now you expect me to get on
this plane and say nothing otherwise
you're going to kick me off the plane
and they said or we'll have you both
arrested
so needless to say i have you know i can
understand your frustration and getting
getting you know pushed around a little
bit but uh i was i was a dedicated
american airlines flyer before that
happened
yeah well everything no not anymore well
it's interesting too because
i i you know like i said i fly
constantly and i feel like maybe i just
wasn't paying attention before but now
now i notice that their their flights
are cheaper than everyone else's
every time i have to book i'm like of
course spending hundreds of dollars more
every week and i'm like i haven't told
you you could have just put the mask on
i know
i told my i told my assistant ball i was
like just write him a letter and tell
him whatever they want to hear just be
like he's sorry he feels bad
like i don't just tell them whatever
they want united's not that bad
yeah united thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you